when I was 19 years old I was angry at
both my parents because I was 19 I
remember blaming them for everything I
literally blamed them for being a bad
person and I remember realizing that
when I blamed them that I gave them
control over my life and then the idea
that the people that I hated the most at
the time were the ones who actually were
controlling me was the thing that most
sickened me to then actually flip my
narrative to actually taking control
like that was the one thought process my
mother I'm giving her control over my
romantic Rel like my mother controls
this that just the idea that
somebody had that much power is what
gave me the power to start taking action